affordable healthcare is important to me
because everybody deserves to have good
healthcare and when you think about it
it saved my life and I remember when I
took my physical and they told me I had
HIV over 22 years ago if it wasn't for
that quality health care that I have and
the plan that I had I probably would
have been dead so I'm glad that I had
good health insurance a good plan and
also too you never know when you're
gonna need it
it's very important young people they
think they're Superman like nothing's
ever gonna happen to them but trust me
one day something's going to happen and
you're gonna need a quality health plan
so make sure you get a bomber care what
a fleets don't understand you're going
to get hurt I don't care who you are
whether it's literally peewee league all
the way up to junior high high school
college and maybe in the pros if you're
fortunate enough to make it you're going
to get injured in my second year with
the Lakers
I tore my knee up torn cartilage it was
my first major injury and so man I
didn't know how having insurance and a
great health plan would work well I
found out then and so I had to rehab the
insurance had to pay for that and then
all the doctor bills piled up but the
insurance took care of that and at the
end of the day I was so happy that I had
a great plan and and I was able to come
back and be the same type of player that
I was before I got injured playing just
like magic no matter how rich poor
middle class no matter what color you
are everybody deserves to have good
quality health care and what I'm really
excited about is that the fact that now
every key can go get their shots get
their checkups their physicals parents
you know get their physicals because the
early detection
can save people's lives I'm living proof
of that